Stephen Strange
the illuminati will see you now we will
see what kind of doctor strange you are
Welcome back everyone this will be my full doctor
strange two breakdown easter eggs for the entire
movie there are so many things we have to talk
about so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos careful
for spoilers for the movie if you haven't seen it
yet we'll be talking about everything that
happens because they set up a lot of stuff
we'll just start at the beginning and work our
way through shot by shot talking about easter
eggs wtf moments as we go along so the first big
thing is this movie is notable because it's one
of the few marvel movies where the director
of the movie dropped out before the sequel so
scott derrickson who's mostly known for directing
hardcore r-rated traditional horror movies left
the movie originally he'd hyped it up about being
marvel's first horror film that's what allows sam
raimi to come back to the marvel universe direct
a new marvel movie even though technically this is
his first mcu movie now toby maguire's spider-man
movies that he directed are canon to the mcu
marvel cinematic multiverse technically but he's
also had a long history of directing horror films
with a lot of comedy in them most notably the
evil dead series with a lot of bruce campbell
in them there's a lot of references for those
films in this including bruce campbell himself
but a lot of the horror elements the camera
techniques that they used during the film were
specific sam raimi techniques that you see
in his other films like when they take first
person perspective when scarlet witch is chasing
them down all across different parts of the film
he also uses a lot of jump scares especially at
the ends of his films kind of like they do at the
end of this film with doctor strange casually
walking down the street like it's no big deal
until he clutches his head in pain as the third
eye emerges they start with the marvel phase 4
logo it's updated to include mostly doctor strange
specific footage inside the logo itself they do
this for a lot of the marvel phase 4 movies and
in some cases like the Wandavision series or the
loki series they'll give them custom marvel intros
that'll look way different this series serves as
sort of a continuation of Wandavision as if they
had a Wandavision episode 10 11 12. originally
doctor strange was supposed to show up at the
end of Wandavision and do a lot of what you see
him do during this movie but the actual opening
scene is of mcu doctor strange having a vision
of defender strange in america chavez inside the
multiverse waypoint trying to get the book of the
vashanti and use it as a solution to defeat this
demon that they think is chasing america this is
before they've learned that it's mcu scarlet witch
using runes to use other creatures to go after her
before she goes after her herself early in
the movie they try to foreshadow that it's
really her because you see the same runes on both
creatures on this creature here in the waypoint
and then on gargantos later they made a big deal
about runes and witchcraft during Wandavision
they specifically referenced which craft as
in the scarlet witch during this movie runes
in a given space only the witch who cast them can
use her magic the runes are why doctor strange
can't use any magic when he goes to visit mcu
scarlet witch at the mountain hideaway from the
end of Wandavision in that post-credits scene
it's the same place that we saw her at in the
post-credits scene it's just that when he arrives
there she's created a new version of the hex which
is why everything looks the way that it does
there are many many variants in the movies of
all the main characters variants of the avengers
variants of brand new teams like patrick stewart's
professor x john krasinski's reed richards i'll
talk more specifically about them later in the
video when we get to that part of the movie
but this particular variant of doctor strange
is called defender strange because he looks and
he's wearing a costume exactly like the version
of doctor strange from the defenders comics he's
also wearing a costume looking very similar to
the version of doctor strange from the recent
secret wars event which is what they're teasing
during this movie with all the incursions america
chavez most of you will recognize from the comics
her backstory is pretty similar to what it is in
the comics she's born in another pocket dimension
but when she's younger accidentally activates
her powers and sends her parents and herself
to alternate universes she can also enhance her
regular attacks with the cosmic energy that she
uses to punch holes through different universes
the way they explain her character in the mcu is
that she's one of the first people that they
know of that the avengers have actually met
who can physically travel across universes in a
conscious way but not the first person to actually
come from an alternate universe we just saw that
happen during spider-man no way home but that
was because of a spell that had gone awry pulling
people from alternate dimensions that's how toby
maguire andrew garfield all the other sinister
six characters the many many alternate spider-man
characters at the end of the film almost wound
up on planet earth which surprisingly they also
canonized now as the official 616 universe which
is the main universe of the comics like the main
continuity turns out mysterio wasn't lying about
that he was lying about all kinds of stuff during
that spider-man far from home movie but not about
the mcu being the 616 universe there's also an
easter egg for this during the loki series
because when loki's variant is watching his
original origin story play out and he sees his
own death the original loki who died is canonized
as loki 616 as in the loki from the 616 universe i
know a lot of you are asking what's the difference
between an alternate timeline in that version of
a variant versus an alternate universe version of
a variance versus an alternate dimension marvel
tends to yada yada yada a lot of that explanation
they're all technically different concepts like a
timeline is different from an alternate universe
is different from an alternate dimension but they
might just combine a lot of those concepts because
mostly we're just building up two secret wars
in this giant multiverse event which i think
will be connected to the kang multiverse war just
based on the way they simplify everything so that
everybody and your grandma can understand what's
actually going on they're going after the book
of the vishanti from the comics but in the mcu it
simply just contains anything that someone might
need to vanquish their foe if you cast the spell
that's inside it it will just produce whatever
item or scenario you need to win a battle the 838
universe illuminati claimed that they used it to
defeat their version of thanos on titan before
they killed their doctor strange in the comics
the book is just meant to be a repository for
the most powerful lightside good spells in the
multiverse the vashanti are a huge deal in the
comics though they're like a trio of gods like
we've been learning about gods on moon knight
who are like the gods of order in the multiverse
kind of like the living tribunal protects order
in the multiverse which we actually see later in
the film don't worry i'll talk about the living
tribunal they're made up of hoggoth the god of
an alien race oshter one of the elder gods from
the same pantheon is cthon who's also mentioned
in the movie there'll be a lot of questions about
how to pronounce his name too and the third member
of the vashanti is oshter's son agamotto the
actual original sorcerer supreme he's kind of
like a thor type character he was born with god
level powers to oster but born as a man oster
kind of created him in a magical way the same way
that scarlet witch created her children billy and
tommy using magic agamoto started spending a bunch
of his time on earth studying magic he created
the ancient temple beneath the new york sanctum
that they referenced in spider-man no way home
he created the eye of agamotto the third eye in
sinister strange's forehead as well as the third
eye that appears in mcu doctor strange's forehead
at the end of the film is called the aya bhagamoto
it's meant to represent when a sorcerer
has gained a certain level of power
eventually agamoto chose to embrace a more
cosmic role more of his god powers and became
one of these god's magical order in the comics
they have a special contract with doctor strange
and he draws most of his magical energy to power
his spells from them the same way black panther
has a special contract with boss the panther
goddess to gain most of his mystical powers
but doctor strange isn't meant to be the avatar
of the vashanti like moonite is the avatar of
kanchu he just has a contract with them so
he's not their slave or anything like that
the waypoint place in the mcu here where the book
is kept is just meant to be the space between all
universes like a trained depot so to speak during
the movie different characters are trying to suck
out america chavez's power for themselves we saw
this same effect previously on Wandavision when
agatha harkness tried to suck out scarlet witch's
chaos magic for herself mcu doctor strange wakes
up after having visions of his alternate selves
and different characters that are powerful enough
or special enough can actually witness the events
of their alternate selves in these other universes
sometimes but it's not meant to be the same as
dream walking dreamwalking is when you legit
physically control someone else supplanting
their mind with your own across universes
he takes the broken watch that mcu christine
palmer gave him and heads to her wedding ceremony
at the ceremony he speaks with one of the former
surgeon co-workers from the first film before he
became doctor strange about the 1 in 14 million
plan allowing thanos to snap half the universe
several times during the movie different
characters will reference this and whether or
not he actually made the right call and make him
question whether or not there was an alternate way
to defeat thanos did he have to sacrifice iron man
to save the universe because literally we learned
that the illuminati wound up using the book of the
vashanti and they did not have to sacrifice their
doctor strange to kill thanos they just killed him
after the fact because of very different reasons
a lot of you now wondering if they can actually
use some time travel now because of what's going
on with king the conqueror for doctor strange
to quote unquote take back his mistake and use
that way to bring back iron man somehow in
the mcu but really what's going on here is
this whole storyline for doctor strange in the
movie is meant to reference his character arc
learning not to always feel like he has to be the
one controlling everything because typically it
just leads to really bad things happening when
he tries to control everything like sinister
strange is meant to be the worst case scenario of
that what i think this is all setting up all this
infinity war 1 in 14 million talk about him always
making the wrong call is there foreshadowing
that our mcu doctor strange will get an iron man
similar arc and will eventually sacrifice himself
doing the similar type of thing that iron man did
falling on the sword to save the day instead of
pulling another avengers end game infinity war
scenario where he forces someone else to fall on
the sword and that'll probably wind up happening
during their big time runs out secret wars movie
series whatever winds up happening with that
because that's what the movie is teasing secret
wars with all these incursions ending that arc
is where you would basically end this mcu doctor
strange's story the same way you ended iron
man's story with a big sacrifice they also used
the actual wrist watch that mcu christine palmer
gave him as a literal reference and metaphorical
reference to his arc he uses the watch to
open the waypoint his alternate self created
because in every universe mostly versions of him
have some kind of relationship with the version of
christine palmer most of the versions blowing it
with their christine palmer but they do set up a
potential romance with this universe 838 version
of christine which seems way cooler than the mcu
christine anyway apparently mcu christine palmer
met her husband during that five-year time gap
but her husband is a huge doctor strange fanboy
there are a couple points in the film where they
joke about this all the avengers now are basically
celebrities so they always have funny moments with
people trying to get their autographs or take
their picture like during the hawkeye series
someone tries to get his autograph while
he's in the pisser and for most of them
it's not like spider-man's situation with
the whole secret identity being a thing
speaking of which they do reference spider-man a
couple times the events of spider-man no way home
during the film they confirmed that doctor strange
remembers everything that happened everything was
spider-man no way home fighting with spider-man on
titan the events of avengers infinity war avengers
end game it's just that he does not remember and
no one remembers that it's actually peter parker
underneath the mask they just remember a version
of spider-man being there for all this stuff
the funny joke that america chavez and doctor
strange talk about spider-man shooting webs
out of his butt is actually a deep cut for james
cameron's version of spider-man he was going to
do during the 90s during the script that he wrote
for that movie he was going to have his version
of spider-man have a wet dream and basically
instead of the you know usual problem happening
when you have a wet dream he was actually going
to get all excited and shoot webs out of himself
so webs were really going to come out of all of
his extremities i'd rather not talk about this
no i don't mean to are you teasing me no no no
no as you can imagine sony decided to not go in
that direction when they hired sam raimi to do
tony mcguire's version of spider-man like okay
he has organic web shooters but he's not needing
to shoot webs out of his junk or out of his butt
gargantos attacks in the street he changes into
his regular robes the cloak of levitation to save
america chavez in the movie the whole thing they
have going on with this is gargantos actually
looks more like classic schumacher from the comics
who's more of a legit doctor strange villain
but the whole problem they have with this is that
schumacher's actually belongs to the conan ip and
right now marvel doesn't have the rights to that
so they just called the creature gargantos even
though he looks like schumacher in for instance
shumagorth comes from an interdimensional place he
was born in a place kind of like the waypoint they
visit where the book of the vishanti is kept but
if this had been actual shumogor there's no way
they would have been able to kill him like this
because for instance dormammu was the student
of schumacher he studied a lot of his magic
underneath him that's how powerful shoe mcgorth
is as per tradition a lot of the signs all over
the frames are all filled with numbers and
easter eggs on the bus it reads number 6192
that's a reference to comic book infinity wars
in the movie calling back to mcu infinity war
obviously on the left side of the frame the
sign reads magic plus t which foreshadows the
universe 838 sorcerer's supreme bear mordo using
the magic tee to knock them out on the right side
of the frame the cab reads p307 the closest
reference i can think of is because this is
sam raimi directing the movie is a reference to
spider-man 3 which came out in 2007 starring toby
maguire's peter parker which we just saw in the
mcu also in this scene they have the street corner
pizza place which you could think of as another
spider-man 2 pizza time reference as pizza becomes
a big recurring theme in the movie with bruce
campbell's pizza balls later in the illuminati's
universe in america chavez saying that she
eats pizza in every universe that she goes to
pizza time surprisingly despite having a genius
level intellect we learn mcu doctor strange has
not taken the time to learn spanish but wang does
speak it i already explained all the spider-man
jokes that they tell during the movie but also
america chavez explains that she has not been
to a universe yet where there is a version of
spider-man like it's a brand new concept to her
so she hasn't been to toby mcguire's universe she
hasn't been to andrew garfield's universe or the
venom universe wong reveals there are secret
books and information that you get on top of
everything when you become sorcerers supreme
i think this is just to allow them some room
in the future with some kind of plot twist when
doctor strange three or whenever secret roars
rolls around with them whipping out more secret
books of magic that they didn't know about before
because he has not become sources of supreme yet
then we see mcu scarlet witch having the same type
of dream vision that doctor strange just had into
her universe 838 self in a version of their house
in west view with her children billy and tommy
they even play the music cue from Wandavision a
lot of the music gets reused from Wandavision
in the previous doctor strange movies the way
elizabeth olsen explained these alternate versions
of scarlet witch she said that because she's not
wearing a wedding band in any of these alternate
scenes in this alternate reality there's no
version of vision in the equation and they've just
broken up or separated at some point in the past
but because there is a version of billy and tommy
who exist here and in many other universes they
had something similar to the events of the hex go
down but somehow she was able to perma-keep her
children they didn't vanish when she took the hex
down the way elizabeth olsen explained all this
is that she said they wanted the story to be about
her just getting back to a version of her children
and incorporate the multiverse because they wanted
to lead up to secret wars so that's why in the
movie you don't see her searching the multiverse
for another version of vision or trying to find
mcu white vision and why they didn't have her just
try to create another version of billy and tommy
in the mcu doing the same thing she did last time
it is the same version of the actors who played
billy and tommy on wandavision and i believe they
ended the movie with billy and tommy the way they
did with scarlet witch agreeing to not search the
multiverse anymore just kind of leave all these
alternate versions on other worlds to their own
families is so that in the future when they do a
young avengers movie or a young avengers series
they can bring back older versions of billy and
tommy from the future of some other universe
played by different adult actors and it'll make
sense you'd be like oh these are just different
variants from another universe but they still
feel like family is forever there's that quote
during the movie that she has family is forever
which is also a quote from Wandavision so the idea
is that when mcu scarlet witch eventually does
come back don't worry i'll get to that too because
elizabeth olsen was talking about the way that her
character ended she'll still feel like these other
variants that might show up in the future who are
adults are still her family her children even
though they're technically from another universe
kevin feige always thinking like 10 years
ahead then doctor strange goes to visit
mcu scarlet witch at the same place she was
at during the Wandavision post-credits scene
studying the darkhold she references her version
of vision having told her about the dangers of
the multiverse the existence of the multiverse
previously which is actually where she got the
idea to search for alternate versions of billy
and tommy the reason why everything eventually
turns around her looking red and dead is because
the dark hole is meant to corrupt the user and
corrupting everything around it so if she'd been
using the dark hole for instance in the middle of
new york city for this long then there'd be like
a whole city block of new york city that would
look like a wasteland doctor strange makes a joke
about bug themed avengers that's a spider-man no
way home reference and an ant-man 3 reference
because obviously we just saw no way home and
we're getting ant-man 3 at the beginning of next
year which would be like the next big piece of
this secret wars puzzle with kang the conqueror
in the kang multiverse war he also jokes about
getting herself back on the avengers lunch box
merch that's another Wandavision hex reference
like i said there was going to be a deleted scene
at the end of the Wandavision finale where doctor
strange showed up and sort of took her to task
about what she had done because even before she
starts killing people during the movie going after
america chavez she was considered a fugitive on
the land like she was hiding out from the law
which they do briefly reference like doctor
strange says no you did a lot of wrong stuff but
i'm not here to talk about that so that's them
kind of hand waving over the end of Wandavision
like yes you were definitely a fugitive from the
law but we have multiverse problems here so
that's more important then when he learns the
truth about her really being behind all this she
uses what he did during avengers infinity war in
avengers end game with the infinity gauntlet in
the snap another reference to him messing with the
multiverse and technically maybe making the wrong
call and messing with the multiverse again during
spider-man no way home as justification for what
she's doing when he tries to tell her that her
children are not real you created them with magic
her big clap back is that don't all mothers create
their children with magic metaphorically they
have their big battle during kamartage and the
way they portray scarlet witch during this movie
is that she's meant to be the most powerful magic
user inside the mcu but the whole thing is doctor
strange is way more learned he's a much smarter
magician so he uses that to try and keep her at
bay but if you think about it none of the regular
characters that you expect are actually able to
defeat her they're not able to stop her doctor
strange none of the other illuminati characters
is actually the version of billy and tommy who
cause her to chill and realize what she's done
and that's why she stops if she decided to keep
going they would've had to go one step up to the
living tribunal or someone even more powerful
like where's the beyonder where's that version of
franklin richards seriously though they mentioned
franklin richards in this movie he is like the
most powerful living humanoid character in the
marvel universe next to the beyonder but he's like
a little kid maybe adult franklin richards would
be able to stop scarlet witch the other big thing
they show you during this battle is that the order
from all the different sanctums all unite from
across the planet to fight at comartaj because
that's sort of like their connective waypoint
where they all go to study they also introduced
the wrentra minotaur who's another big magical
character from the comics she starts messing with
people's minds which is a big call back to her
giving everyone visions in age of ultron but she
also did that during Wandavision he tries to trap
her in the mirror dimension but she's so powerful
she uses the reflections against them in the room
and is able to escape way quicker than doctor
strange was when spider-man trapped him in that
same dimension you know what's cooler than magic
math you notice her fingers have turned black just
like agatha hardness is because both of them have
been corrupted by a long-term use of the darkhold
and the whole thing with this corruption that you
get from the book is actually part of the plot
with catholic he's like the god of chaos the
origin of scarlet witch's chaos magic they claim
in the mcu that he's the person who created the
original darkhold temple in every copy that you
see of the book in the mcu across the multiverse
which is transcribed from that original one
temple so there's only one dark hole temple
for the entire multiverse an mcu scarlet witch is
meant to be the main scarlet witch conquering the
entire multiverse but the whole idea is that cthon
did that to take advantage of her and himself
conquer the entire multiverse he's part of this
pantheon of elder gods that ruled over the mcu
dimension a long time ago until he was kicked out
and he's been trying to use ways like the darkhold
chaos magic to break back in and take over ever
since they give him a little bit of an upgrade
during this movie saying that he's trying to use
the dark hole temple scarlet witch is a sort of
backdoor to conquer the entire multiverse he's
the person in the comics who gave scarlet witch
or chaos magic when she was born as part of
this sort of grand plan to use her to conquer
everything eventually but i think part of the idea
is that they wouldn't actually show him on screen
unless they do an actual scarlet witch solo movie
which it sounds like they might do at some point
because if you don't see a body like at the end
of the movie she blows up the temple if you don't
see a body that means that they're not dead common
comic book language elizabeth olsen also said that
she believes that scarlet witch is still alive
at the end of the film is wanda really dead what
is the future of wanda she could never go away i
don't think especially with the multiverse but i
don't know i i think she's i think she's aware
of what she's what she's done um but no i don't
think she's gone when scarlet witch says that
she killed her own husband and it meant nothing
ultimately it's just sick infinity war burn
because she's referencing how she killed vision to
try and destroy the mind stone to prevent thanos
from getting it but all he had to do was just use
the time stone to rewind time so she killed him
for nothing then they go through a huge montage of
a bunch of different universes all of them having
really funny really cool easter eggs they start
with them passing by the legit actual mcu living
tribunal which is meant to be a big infinity war
deleted scene callback originally during the
mcu infinity war when they were having their
battle on titan doctor strange was going to take
thanos on this grand tour of the multiverse like
he went on and at the end of it he was going to
take him to the mcu living tribunal to be judged
they deleted it for obvious reasons because it
just became too extra like they'd have to explain
who is the living tribunal and thanos was going
to wind up beating him anyway because he was gonna
wind up snapping the infinity gauntlet at the end
of the film no matter what it's supposed to be
one of the most powerful cosmic characters in the
entire multiverse next to the one above all which
is like the one true god of the entire multiverse
the next place they go is just this place of pure
energy then they crash through a dimension that's
just pure crystalline then they travel through a
version of new york city which is populated by
giant insects then they travel through a version
of earth where new york is totally underwater like
it doesn't exist it's all underwater then there's
another more regular version of new york city
with a grindhouse movie easter egg which is like a
whole genre of movies grindhouse movies typically
low budget really hardcore types of films
you can think of the original evil dead movie like
the really low budget evil dead movie as being a
grindhouse type of film then there's a universe
where everything is super advanced hyper efficient
like there are tubes running around everywhere
then they travel through a hell-like universe
where everything in new york city here is on fire
and dead there are skeletons climbing around in
the background and screaming they travel through
a universe that's still in the jurassic era period
with dinosaurs that could also be an easter
egg for the savage land from the x-men comics
they travel through an animated universe and
the animation does kind of look like the 3d
animation style from what if so you could call it
the what-if universe but technically on that show
it was like the entire multiverse was animated
it wasn't just one universe then there's an ice
universe where everything is frozen over with
green magic energy as if the planet has been
taken over by loki it's meant to be a big thor
movie reference like it's a universe where loki
conquered the planet and it became a frost giant
colony which they also kind of did during the what
if series where loki winds up conquering the
earth there's a block universe which i think
we're just calling the minecraft universe there's
a paint universe that they reference later in the
film where everything exists as paint america
chavez says that you shouldn't get stuck there
because it's really hard to put stuff in
your mouth and eat when your body is paint
there's a black and white 1930s universe with a
mickey mouse looney tunes style laughing it's just
them screaming like their screen continues and
the screen changes form like the sound changes
form because you exist differently in different
universes but the reason why it looks that way why
it sounds that way is because i think that it's
meant to be a steamboat willy reference like it's
a reference to the origin of disney itself because
marvel is owned by disney now there's a universe
where the cree have conquered earth and turned it
into their colony then there's another advanced
universe that looks all blade runner we'll call
this the spider-man 2099 universe we actually saw
a version of him during spider-man across the
spider-verse trailer oscar isaac mcu moonite
also plays their spider-man 2099 there's another
hyper-advanced universe where everything looks all
clean as if it's designed to look kind of like an
apple store they travel through a universe where
it seems like humanity either never developed
or suffered some catastrophe in the earth broke
apart because it's all covered in lava flows and
because we're getting the obi-wan kenobi episodes
you can also think of this as like the mustafar
looking universe with lava everywhere like they
do actually have the high ground literally during
the scene when they're flying through the air
then they finally wind up in the 838 universe the
illuminati's universe and everything just looks
all utopian the number 838 isn't meant to be a
comic book reference to anything specifically
it's just something that they created for the
movie but because the way they explain things
in this universe they have a version of the x-men
mutants who exist everywhere they have a version
fantastic four their version of captain carter
had an origin story similar to the version from
what if where peggy carter got the super soldier
serum from steve rogers the inhumans exist in this
universe because ants and mount black bolt
the territory miss and the way they explain
all these versions is that they're meant to be
similar to what we've seen before like some of
them are big easter eggs obviously but they're
meant to be brand new versions in this universe
they had a version of their infinity war at some
point they developed the illuminati team to fight
thanos other big threats instead of just letting
the avengers or other teams handle everything by
themselves they make a lot of references to the
illuminati being this think tank team making a
lot of hard choices they kind of have this
sinister vibe to them that's exactly right
out of the comics brian michael bendis created the
team and it was just meant to be the most powerful
characters in the marvel universe coming together
to solve even bigger cosmic level problems
they revealed that in their universe their version
of doctor strange tried to take on thanos himself
saw a lot of these problems their self using the
darkhold and dreamwalk looking in the multiverse
but ultimately it just corrupted him and then
they eventually turned to the book of the vishanti
used it to kill their version of thanos as you
see his dead body impaled on titan so the snap
never wound up happening in their universe and
because they felt like their version of doctor
strange only presented a threat long term like
he was turning into a version of sinister strange
ultimately they had their version of black bolt
kill him using his ability they make a joke about
food across the multiverse mostly being free in
all universes like it's weird that it costs money
in your universe but apparently it also costs
money in this universe too because they have bruce
campbell's big cameo scene he's selling papa's
pizza balls on the street and yells at them about
paying for their food bruce campbell most people
will remember from all of sam raimi's movies in
some way most notably for playing ash during the
evil dead series and a lot of tropes from those
movies wind up being tropes during doctor strange
multiverse of madness but he also cameoed during
all sam raimi's spider-man films and would have
also cameoed in tobey maguire spider-man 4 as a
version of mysterio had that wound up happening
doctor strange winds up enchanting his body to
attack itself it's also meant to be a reference
to the evil dead series where ash's hand gets
possessed and starts attacking him until he
cuts it off that's how he got his chainsaw hand
in those movies the second post-credits scene is
meant to be a big joke about that they set up his
cloak of levitation tearing so the 838 christine
can repair it and it starts to look more comic
book accurate but his costume just in general in
this movie is much more comic accurate than in
previous movies their version of mordo sorcerer
supreme uses the t in the sands of nisanti to
put them both to sleep in the comics the sands do
the exact same thing they just temporarily negate
people's magical powers and in the movie christine
explains that she created these special gauntlets
to just dampen all of his powers when mcu scarlet
witch dreamwalks to possess a 3a scarlet witch
behind her on tv you see billy and tommy are
watching a version of oswald the lucky rabbit
that's meant to be the precursor for the actual
original mickey mouse cartoon steamboat willie
which is another big disney callback they also
watch a version of snow white which is meant to
be more of a literal reference to their mother
being put to sleep so to speak trapped in her
own mind while mcu scarlet witch controls her body
back at comartaj they explained that the darkhold
will destroy anyone who tries to destroy it but
like i explained earlier it's just meant to be a
copy of the writings inside the darkhold temple
that catholic built in ancient times when they
say it's on mount wondergore that's meant to be a
big reference to scarlet witch and quicksilver's
origin story in the comics they were taken to one
degree by the cow person called bova after they
were born to magneto and magna the only difference
is that when they were taken there they were taken
to the high evolutionary's castle even though
he doesn't really figure into their backstory
right here in the mcu as far as we know we will
meet mcu high evolutionary during guardians of
the galaxy 3 so i think his origin story will
be just a little bit different there was an
easter egg for bova during Wandavision though but
she isn't meant to be the same type of minotaur
that rin trot is they're both completely
different types of characters the chaos magic
beasts that they find protecting the temple are
designed to look kind of like cthon was so his
face kind of looks like this there's an image of
scarlet witch on the back wall that's identical to
the one inside the dark hold and some of the texts
and symbols on the walls also look kind of like
the symbols from the eternals movie which i think
is just meant to be a connection to the ancient
nature of catholic himself like the celestials
themselves are ancient so is cathon the god of
chaos the reason why he choose this particular
universe to build the darkhold temple and use this
main version of scarlet witch to conquer the
entire multiverse is because they explained
during spider-man no way home they're these crazy
powerful cosmic magical ley lines that run through
this particular universe's version of earth and
a lot of things are built to take advantage of
that that's why agamotto built this ancient
temple to take advantage of those ley lines
is the same reason why catholic would have built
the darkhold temple in this particular universe
when he meets the illuminati he's escorted to the
chamber by the variants of the ultron robots they
even reference the ultron protocol except in this
reality they were able to control them and use
them for good they're basically this universe's
version of iron man's iron legion but we don't
actually see this universe's version of iron
man so either he wasn't around or he wasn't on
this iteration of the team or just gave them some
of his tech or he died at some point before the
movie so there was some iron man stuff during the
film but not actual iron man variants on screen
there's a seventh empty chair in the illuminati
chamber i believe that the empty chair would
have belonged to his character because baron mordo
would have replaced a version of doctor strange so
it's not like there have been eight chairs for
iron man then when they introduce each of the
different members they play some of their classic
music cues like when they introduce captain carter
they play some of the classic captain america
music they call her the first avenger in this
universe just like mcu captain america she looks
exactly like the version from what if she says the
iconic line during the movie too i could do this
all day i can do this all day yeah i know i know
then even though this universe's version of baron
mordo had replaced doctor strange on the team they
never explained what happened to mcu baron mordo
another lot of questions about that but the actor
said that mcu mordo did not get snapped and he's
still alive out there somewhere inside the mcu
they have anson mount playing a version of black
bolt he was also from the inhumans tv series
they also referenced the terrigen myth so just
the inhumans in general are canon to the mcu
now through the multiverse they have a version of
maria rambo who's captain marvel her origin story
because she's a test pilot just like carol danvers
is that on the day when they had that big accident
with the tesseract pilot she just happened to be
the one flying the plane instead of carol danvers
and if you haven't watched a lot of those
movies maria rambo is the mother of monica rambo
monica rambo will actually come back during the
marvels movie captain marvel 2. she also has
powers too but different types of powers they have
john krasinski playing reed richards fulfilling
all of our fan casting dreams fantastic four now
canon to the mcu through the multiverse they call
him the smartest man alive that's another comic
book reference too they also referenced the baxter
foundation the baxter building which we all kind
of think has taken the place of the old avengers
tower and at least in this universe he said he's
already married to a version of sue storm and they
have both of their children franklin richards
and valeria richards when they joke about them
charting in the 60s he's making a joke about the
origin story of the fantastic four because they
debuted during the early 60s and it's also meant
to be a beatles joke like the four beatles they're
the very first family of superheroes that stan
lee ever created in the comics which is why kevin
feige later referred to them as marvel's first
family in the movie they're creating in the mcu
i'm happy to announce a film about one
of the truly iconic marvel families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic four then
they introduced patrick stewart's professor x who
like i said is meant to be a variant very similar
to the one from the x-men animated series he's
got the same yellow chair he's wearing the exact
same costume as that version of professor x and
when he floats in on the same yellow chair they
also play the x-men animated series theme song
when scarlet witch starts attacking them their
professor x also repeats a line of dialogue
which is from x-men days of future past when he
tells our doctor strange just because someone
stumbles and loses their way doesn't mean that
they are lost forever the funny thing about the
scarlet witch versus the illuminati fight is
that a lot of the techniques she uses a lot
of the vibe of the character is her going full
thanos from avengers infinity war and avengers
end game doing some of the similar things similar
types of attacks that he used during those movies
you took everything from me i don't even know who
you are except make it scarlet witch for instance
she turns reed richards into ribbons the same
way thanos did to the guardians of the galaxy
for the most part most of these members of the
illuminati wind up getting killed but not all of
them get killed patrick stewart himself said that
he was planning on coming back too so even though
he does get killed during the movie he said he'll
probably come back as a different variant in some
future film so for instance john krasinski can
come back to do the fantastic four movie in the
mcu he can also direct it now too because john
watts isn't doing it anymore but when professor
x goes into her mind to try and stop her free the
original wanda the place he enters with this door
the rubble is designed to look like a version
of her house from Wandavision all destroyed
a metaphor for mcu wanda destroying the life of
the other wanda so she can take it for herself
also her being buried under all this rubble is
a callback to the young wanda as a child being
trapped in all the rubble of her house the stark
tech missile but r.i.p because she snaps his neck
too when they're running through the basement of
the illuminati base you see all this old paperwork
this old timey stuff down here this is meant to be
a call back like you saw during avengers end game
all this is meant to belong to professor x because
he would have been very active during the 60s
so it's like an avengers end game when they go
into the old camp lehigh base in the 70s and you
see all this old timey tech i believe the idea
is that this whole mansion here this whole area
is professor xavier's mansion like it belongs
to him financially they go into the waypoint
but scarlet witch winds up burning the book
of the vashanti there was only one for the
entire multiverse so it doesn't exist anymore
but the actual vishanti gods who created are
still around so they can always go to them unless
score the god butcher winds up killing them too
they wind up going to sinister strange's universe
and it's basically what we thought it was from the
comics just a universe where reality is basically
collapsed on itself and is about to die pretty
much the same thing that happened to the universe
from what if where supreme strange destroyed
his entire universe trying to gain more power
sinister strange explained that he'd gotten so
bad he started killing doctor strangers in other
universes by dreamwalking and forcing them to kill
themselves by just having them walk their bodies
off of ledges he also says that he lost some giant
multiverse battle to someone but never says who i
think that he was talking about king the conqueror
or a version of him because so much of the movie's
foreshadowing secret wars this giant multiverse
battle and alternate universes and that's
basically what a version of the kang multiverse
war is he whips out his third eye from the comics
and even though he has been corrupted by his use
of the darkhold he's super evil the third eye
itself isn't meant to be inherently evil it's
basically a manifestation of the ibagamoto which
is like a power that sorcerers can attain after
they've expanded their abilities to a certain
point same thing happens to our doctor strange
at the end of the movie he manifests his third eye
because he's become so much more powerful learns
so much more but also just like sinister strange
he's been corrupted so there's that threat too
they have their big musical battle danny elfman
who did music for the movie also wrote special
music for the battle itself when they're literally
grabbing notes off the page and turning them into
weapons against each other after he kills sinister
strange they wind up using the dark hole to
dreamwalk into the dead body of defender strange
which winds up turning him into a big marvel
zombies easter egg then you see all these souls
of the dam that he talks about coming to stop
him because what he's doing is so forbidden on a
magical level i think they're trying to connect
this back to the dark hole chaos magic in cathode
because they say it's the souls of the damned
in agatha harkness called the darkhold the book
of the damned so i think that all just connects
back to cthon they say doctor strange is going
to suffer eternal cosmic consequences because
of what he's doing i think that means eventually
he'll have to face a version of catholic or some
other high-level dimensional demons like marvel's
fearlords nightmare make all the mephisto jokes
that you want the cauldron that christine uses to
save him also seems like the one from the first
doctor strange movie inside the case which might
be another vashanti reference she says praise you
above the light as she activates it then when
america chavez uses wanda's children against
her she frightens them so badly they think she's
like the wicked witch of the west which they had a
bunch of references to during Wandavision and it's
her children who cause her to realize what she's
done she chills out she frees everyone destroys
the dark cold temple remember it's the only temple
in the entire multiverse which consequently winds
up destroying all copies of the darkhold across
the multiverse i think that's more to let you
know that in the future someone isn't going to be
able to just whip out another darkhold and do the
exact same thing that they did during this movie
there is a flash of chaos magic as the temple
kind of crumbles around itself and like i said
elizabeth olsen said she's not dead there have
been rumors about them doing a scarlet witch solo
movie at some point they wind up taking christine
back to her illuminati universe and kind of set up
a possible romance between her and mcu doctor
strange we'll see how clea feels about that
too because she was married to doctor strange in
the comics for a long time america chavez starts
training in kamar tash she references the sling
rings being so hard to use that's a callback to
the first doctor strange movie with him not being
able to open portals on his first try they set
up her whole arc finding her parents in another
universe someday like i said they came originally
from pocket universe so they might be singular
amongst the multiverse she said that there are
no variants of her in any universe so she's like
the true meaning of a nexus being inside the
comics there's meant to be only one version of her
for the entire multiverse doctor strange finally
bows to huang which they had referenced earlier in
the movie because he's sorcerer supreme and then
repairs the watch mcu christine gave him is a way
to put a bow on his character arc from the movie
like he's learned a lot but it's kind of ironic
because even though he's fixing the watch he's not
fixing reality things just get worse as implied by
the post credit scene he walks out on the street
all happy then in the classic sam raimi record
drop moment drops to his knee starts screaming as
the third eye emerges on his forehead but it's not
all a bad thing like him getting the third eye as
an expression of how powerful he's gotten but then
right after that during the first post-credits
scene charlize theron's clea from the comic shows
up from the dark dimension to tell him that he's
just caused another incursion and they're going
to go fix it taking him back to the dark hole
dimension so if you don't know who khalia is she's
actually a really big deal she is doctor strange's
true love interest from the comics she's another
ultra powerful sorceress from the dark dimension
and she's the daughter of the former ruler of this
dark dimension before dormammu took over she's
actually dormammu's niece she's the daughter of
dormammu's twin sister but obviously that's just
teasing more universes colliding with each other
in a big time runs out scenario we'll have to
combine the fragments of the limited multiverse
that's left into a single battle world scenario
maybe they'll introduce a version of dr doom at
some point and do a legit version of secret wars
the second post-credits scene is just meant to be
a funny tag scene with bruce campbell's pizza ball
seller who looks at his hand then looks at
the camera saying aha is finally over kind
of breaking the fourth wall i talked about this in
my previous video too it's a reference to a couple
of different things like he's breaking the fourth
wall kind of like deadpool like it's a deadpool
joke he's making fun of the movie being over like
haha the movie's finally over and recognizing that
he's a fictional character in the movie it's
also him laughing about doctor strange's spell
being over he's not hitting himself anymore and
it's also meant to be a big sam raimi easter egg
to evil dead with his evil hand not trying to
kill him anymore but there's so many things to
talk about you could watch the movie a billion
more times and there's still more easter eggs
to find that i didn't talk about in the video
so if you did see some that i didn't mention
write them below in the comments i've got a whole
bunch of other bonus videos for really specific
things from the movie plan so if you have any big
questions about things specifically or you want me
to do videos about let me know in the comments
everyone click here for my full doctor strange
2 post credit scene video in easter eggs and
click here for my doctor strange 2 review video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!